[Music]
rick new heisel college football analyst
former ucla colorado washington head
coach joins us on the program we have uh
brian kelly next hour you get one
question
for brian kelly what would you ask him
how much does he like gumbo
this is a monster higher and uh good for
brian he's so deserving of it okay how
do you do this in a
tactful way
leaving notre dame to take a job like
this and everybody from what i'm told
behind the scenes at notre dame was
shocked so how do you do it in a classy
way
well from behind the scenes what i'm
being told is that he and jack
were at odds in terms of upgrades to the
notre dame program wait a minute hold on
rick i got a bad connection there it's
uh we'll see if we can reconnect there
so what were you saying about uh
brian kelly and uh jack swarbrick
well the word on the street is and i
don't have confirmation from brian on
this that they were at odds uh in terms
of upgrades for the program
uh to take it to the next level
and obviously brian's hearing from an
agent that there's this great uh you
know desire for him elsewhere and you
can't blame a guy for going for a 95
million dollar deal and a chance to
recruit the defensive lineman that you
can get at lsu which was exactly the
reason nick saban left michigan state
for lsu
okay explain notre dame in in trying to
get certain how difficult is it you know
the limitations of trying to get players
into notre dame
you're not in charge of two things at
notre dame whereas in a lot of these
schools you can get anybody in so you're
not in charge of admissions
so there's going to be a ceiling as to
what you can do in terms of getting kids
into school
and you're not in charge of discipline
you're going to need how many times have
we seen notre dame with the honor code
kids not being able to play
nick saban puts him in a ride along with
the local security and they're back on
the field so you're not in charge of
those things and those might seem like
little things but those are uh those are
game changers when you're trying to you
know play for the big prizes how does it
work behind the scenes
that you could put a deal together and
it feels like it's a 24-hour period
how did you do it or your agent do it so
you can you can stay clean because you
can say
i didn't speak to anybody but your agent
certainly did
yeah well those those conversations
obviously are going on and
you just make sure that your agent
understands you don't want to be
bothered until it's the appropriate time
what i would say though dan is we need
to move the appropriate time at least a
week later and the reason we can't is
because of this
december signing date
i would advocate i would push all my
fellow coaches or what used to be my
fellow coaches towards going back to a
february signing day
stop this nonsense because the transfer
portal is going crazy you're going to
end up choosing from that met that
buffet line first anyway
and let this coaching carousel wait till
after this weekend
after we've made the term determinations
as to who's in the playoffs to hear gary
barta last night say that the committee
might weigh in that brian kelly's
absence could have a factor in whether
or not notre dame should be in the
college football playoff that's nonsense
yeah and we're doing it to ourselves
coaches just need to wait one more week
for all this carousel to begin and if
we'll move recruiting back to where it
belongs we can uh we can get that
accomplished yeah i said the same thing
about 15 minutes ago that let's say nick
saban was sick and couldn't be in a
playoff game or
uh would they hold it against nick saban
uh the fact that notre dame got this far
and brian kelly's not coaching why am i
penalizing notre dame again for brian
kelly taking the lsu job i i i think
that that's
embarrassing that the committee is going
to use that
i i it's it's unfathomable to me i can't
i can't understand it and if i were a
notre dame player i would be absolutely
irate i mean they're sitting there in
the six hole it doesn't take a lot of
imagination nor a lot of uh you know
chaos this weekend to get notre dame
into the top four
and you know you can argue about their
strength of schedule and such but you
can't sit there and say well their head
coach is gone
that to me is ridiculous you wouldn't
say it if their left guard was gone so
you shouldn't say it because their head
coach is gone better job notre dame usc
lsu
i've always said and you'll know i'm a
west coast honk that the sc job is as
good a job as there is in college
football it sits right in the middle of
southern california which is laden with
talent unfortunately much of that talent
for the pac-12 has been leaving right
the the two quarterbacks that were on
top of the uh
uh of the heisman race cj stroud at ohio
state and bryce young at alabama are
both southern california kids i mean
that's that's where they're from and
lincoln riley coming to
sc
is the best news for not only sc it's
the best news for the pac-12 and
certainly george kleopkopf as he starts
to negotiate the next tv deal then would
you have lsu overnote is lsu a better
job than notre dame
listen
notre dame has the most mystique of any
of the teams in college football and for
that reason it's kind of like a rock
band when they come to your town
everybody wants to go and see and that
makes it exciting it's why they stay as
competitive as they do because for a lot
of kids that's an exciting deal but lsu
every year is going to get the best from
the state of louisiana they're the only
power five school in that state and that
is that is an unbelievable uh
region for great college football talent
in particular defensive front guys and
those guys are the gold bullion of
college football
yeah it sounds strange for somebody like
us you know our age to say that lsu is a
better job than notre dame but the
reality is lsu is a better job than
notre dame
and then it begs the question and this
had to factor in lincoln riley's uh you
know
as he mashed this all up
what is the sec going to be now that
you're adding texas you're adding
oklahoma 16 teams there's probably going
to be 14 pods
lsu if i'm just doing my own pods divvy
up lsu is going to be with a m probably
the two tennessee schools so you're
sitting there going that that's not a
bad gig you're going to have to play
alabama every other year uh but not
every year so maybe not as good but but
that oklahoma gig for uh lincoln riley
to be in the sec recruiting against all
those guys or being in the west coast
and being the uh big fish in the pond
like he is currently in the big 12
adding 110 million dollars to that
package makes that pretty uh attractive
what do you do if you're luke fickle at
cincinnati
well he's got to be the favorite to get
the notre dame job i had it on pretty
good authority that he was very close to
the sc situation but waiting to see what
happened at notre dame uh the question
is was marcus freeman going to leap uh
in front of him and take that job
remember brian kelly pointed out that
marcus freeman was a head coach in
waiting uh whether it was at notre dame
or somewhere else and it's interesting
dan that uh
jack warbrick saying i may not
name an interim i think he would do that
because he wants luke fickle rather than
putting marcus freeman in as the interim
and having the kids all respond to him
as i think we all know that they would
yeah he's the defensive coordinator at
notre dame i wondered about this prior
to the michigan ohio state game if jim
harbaugh had lost last week
could you have seen a scenario where
maybe he looked at it
and said
i've gone as far as i can go here and
maybe i go back to the nfl
i don't think so i think jim harbaugh is
a throwback and it's not just because of
the glasses he wears i think he was
going to send
mount everest until he got to the top
and got to summit and plant a flag and
you know as much as i've had difficulty
with jim in the past it was actually fun
to see him get that done that was his
collegiate scene as i can remember with
all that maze on that sideline in the
aftermath of that win and aiden
hutchinson talking the way he did about
what it meant is everything you love
about college football how tense did it
get between you and jim horrible
oh well in the aftermath of that game
where they beat us 17-9 and i'm driving
down the field and uh just don't get it
in and so i go over to shake his hand
and he slaps my hand and says what do
you think about that ricky
then it got tense
if it was go time how would it have
played out rick
well i probably would have lost but i
would have been in such a pure i would
have just gone for it i mean he's a
little bigger than i am but you know
what i just remember the shock that came
over me and then you remember he did the
same thing to schwartz when he was in
the nfl and schwartz was with the lions
and i was literally watching film that
day uh after our saturday game and i
said he did it again everybody's
wondering what
what the heck is going on i said and
schwartz is going after him and i'm
sitting there you know kind of mad at
myself that i didn't do the same but uh
but no it's listen he is
i i i liking him if he's on your team
you absolutely love him and if he's not
you want the next shot at him but he
called out ryan day after the win over
ohio state he was like hey some guys
wake up on third base and want to tell
you that they hit a triple and i'm like
wow
i'm not into the pop culture and all
this stuff but he is the ultimate
troller ultimate troller
great to talk to you again as always
rick thank you buddy
happy holidays my friend enjoy the
weekend rick new heisel cbs college
football analyst former ucla colorado
and washington head coach